[Music]
in porn history news submitted by hey
look at all the people we got here the
boy means you're great okay so you
people in the comments saying that Josh
is Josh is josh is Josh oh look they all
have made those two good jobs for the
first time in JK news history we have
three black people on because it was
only like bows and maybe the other we've
had bows we've had ricky shucks we've
had DeStorm it's he didn't name all the
black come on this channel yeah that's
why the same with Tim we've had two at a
time individually but never three on
camera together yeah but now we have
three so look at this the editor section
of JK news [ __ ] lit dude yeah we also
have two Filipinos
and one Japanese man just mean okay I
have no Japanese blood it's me okay all
right yeah I was trying to figure out a
way to insert myself into this
conversation T was in Japan so that's
the connection that's how I knew that
the COG mountain his Sugoi over there
cuz like what are you saying over there
but anyway to the story protective dad
asks daughter's boyfriend what his porn
history is like nah and this and this is
so this this girl is dating this guy
obviously and then when he met the
parents he he gave her or he gave him a
questionnaire to talk about a couple
questions see if I can load it up while
he's loading it up what kind of fathers
would you guys be would you guys must be
really protective of your daughters or I
see yeah I think I'd roll the [ __ ] what
do you mean by protective like would you
be like you have a curfew
you can't like watch this [ __ ] [ __ ]
or no I think I I feel like as long as
you have a good communication with your
kid then you don't have to be as
protective yeah introspective so I feel
like my kid would take advantage of that
they would just give me some kind of
questions like well dad what'd you do
this and then like I would just sit
there and just stare into space you
would like spiral off into a corner and
you'd be like alright cool now I can do
what I want what you were saying like my
kid would take advantage of me 1,000%
being your kid he would know how to push
your button how she transitioned like
the child that you have whatever gender
that they are would have figured out how
to press your bus you see how dare you
assume they even have a gender
all right so whatever whatever yeah they
write they is safe days they say they
say whatever they are
JK news getting cancelled for like the
eighth time I feel like we should have a
[ __ ] chalkboard than anything so in
case you guys can see that it's a it's a
paper list but I'm gonna have Antoine
read off oh let's go
the different questions that and imagine
yourself getting this list as you know
dating someone yeah man just a girl I
got his room her father yeah number one
now where do you see yourself in five
years dead I was questioning if your
tribe you serious on my daughter I want
to know what you yeah plan fair to what
qualities do you see in my daughter that
makes you think she will make a good
wife her but also fair Dan you say that
you are out of my house but if you know
I do react to that as like let's say
like a teenager though wife hold on I
only known her for three days I think we
held hands once you make a c-major you
because I think we're assuming as
teenager but we don't know this teenager
no I think it's teenager I'm imagining
controlling dad every teenager at the
oldest college I'm like that I believe
you're in college your dad isn't like
this is insane I'd say my function would
be my guess is teenager as actually the
same thing I got I dated a Christian
girl and oh you know these Christian
girls that were in middle school oh yeah
I think I know if they want to be named
but that was one of the questions that
you would get with an ace to ends with
the show
but he asked that question of like you
know what are your a my your intentions
with my daughter like do you spike this
go somewhere because they mentioned
marriage you know that's that's what
they was the director marriage wasn't
coming but that was alluded to cuz it's
like if you're going to be with my
daughter in the Christian faith you are
sometimes to want to they're supposed to
be courting yeah it was reporting for
marriage interview where you're like I
this relationship is not worth it like
in like my film brain is imagining like
he's like what are your intentions of my
daughter and then it just goes into
Antoine's brain and then you just see
this [ __ ] like baseball badges you
know that scene from office space where
they're all beating up the fritz are in
the princes like yeah here's the hotness
scale and how much I want to deal with
you're not that far up this scale for me
is my problem segue to having the next
question number three is what are your
intentions with my daughter these are
all pretty reasonable I was a teacher
about like the two was five years and
then the second one was do you see my
daughter being a good wife
oh right oh do you see you then in the
intentions number four by the way the
title of this is called son-in-law
material oh yeah yeah the top is
son-in-law material number four how well
can you provide for a wife and family at
this high school a little bit too much
that one's you know and this is the huge
one at number five what is your history
with pornography that don't I'd be like
oh I don't want to deal with this family
yet so ever it's like none of your
[ __ ] business what is your history of
photography Winnett you know be like
here's my hard drive poke funny about
that again being I just came back from
Japan I went to the Osaka
Harry Potter land and there was a show
you his Wang he'd like in the way he was
talking many very so he was he would
from Harry Potter man it was a guy from
Harry Potter land at the Hallward
Express one of the conductor's would
have read he was there standing he came
to us and was like oh what are you doing
here were like oh we just came from
Osaka he's like Oh everybody talks about
this strange place called Osaka hahaha I
was like all he's playing character
really cool he was American or British
or whoever he was he was the important
white dude which is pretty good what is
funny about the theme park is that they
actually put the appropriate appropriate
race there so like they had Marilyn
Monroe it was a white chick that was
Marilyn Monroe wasn't a Japanese wasn't
that many Japanese workers there because
it was Universal Studios right so except
for the jaws one Jaws that's off topic
but jaws the lady there was so great I
don't know what the hell she was saying
but she was the best one ever if you
guys ever go to that go to the jaws
experience but anyway the guy comes up
and goes like have you guys heard of
this thing they call it in Thai and like
really quickly they're just like oh this
wouldn't have happened in Disneyland
this is where the porn begins
and then okay he just tried to be funny
like a high like cuz Lusaka we're in a
place where they had him and then maybe
he went further and he was like yeah
they also have this thing like this
thing that jerks yourself off like what
they know but it's a specific guy
yes I'm like that Tinga Tinga things
like yeah and this thing called tanga
you can do it when you want to have
alone time now where I was like okay now
you propylaia officially creeped out by
you you're on the train he's like way
gone oh by the way hand tired he was
trying to relate to us which is why when
you said that that was like I think the
father relating I'm [ __ ] buzzing why
why us why do you think we're just we're
like American or something that was
trying to make you a wizard right he was
trying to make you know it's so funny
that you like Dumbledore change the word
1/2 penis you have so much fun with with
dirty read all seven books Ron come over
there's like you know the few passages
like you know like Harry's penis spewed
bunch of sparks he like I feel like
there should be an app app Harry's penis
came a deer but yeah the real lady thing
that's what the whole thing I was kicked
out I was like bro I'm done talking to
you like I really checked out looking
around looking this way my crew was to
tell you come on yes I do you have your
one-way ticket to pound oh I might as
well just gone for it does he have the
full list but five is the main thing
yeah what's up yeah
get normal-ish like are there any
activities that you two enjoy doing
together that's a trap guys guys we did
the conversation would be like I mean
like afterwards no just like hey what's
your porn history like if they had that
conversation that's why you wrote it
down so you didn't have to do run what
would you say they lock the door let's
say for instance you're in the locker
room and he says hey you ain't leaving
you cannot get out you have to tell me
what the stuff you pickling like the
point in history I mean at that point
you're lying right you're let you're
sitting there but you're already lying
about everything up to that point out so
he would just look to get out show it
you'd show because my point history is
not that bad oh I'm mostly into amateur
again but like I think I would pass his
test I don't care well I don't know he's
not asking you what your favorite
category
no he's just saying what your
relationship with porn and all it's true
actually yeah what what's your we got oh
I got trapped under God he was Catholic
if he's asked you these questions he's
probably like a heavily religious like
dad no what's point yeah yeah what's
porn that would be like hey you wanna
watch it together
amateur that'd be the wrong answer what
do you think approach it come on what
are these porn video though like what if
he's straight-up like all right well you
know I liked my pornography to be women
female directed that way you know we get
away from all the racial stereotypes on
the abuse of women as well as a lot of
homegrown stuff so it's like you know
American that needs to be equal consent
and and you know like I like when
there's not animal-based products in it
appreciate
is that you put a lot of thought I feel
like a brain would just melt he's just
like you said a lot of good things mixed
in with the things that I have a deep
moral conviction of it and then just
like maybe keel over and die gasps like
the crap out of him that way he doesn't
actually look at your history because I
would you're her stream this is that I
feel like it's the exact opposite of
what you're saying and you say animal
based products I don't think I want to
know what you're listening or watching
any more of this stuff what are these
animal based products that you're
watching
[Music]
[Music]
you